si le vendée globe n'était qu'une partie
de plaisir à force ça se saurait et si
le vendée globe n'était qu'un enfer sas
aurait aussi les marins n'irai pas
simplement entre la ventura risque et la
course de bateaux se glissent de temps à
autre la souffrance le drame et
l'héroïsme lors de la deuxième édition
du vendée globe en 1989 philippe poupon
a déclenché ses deux balises de détresse
son bateau est couché sur l'eau loïck
peyron se déroute et au prix d'une
manoeuvre audacieuse
il va réussir à redresser le monocoque
en perdition pour repartir à réparer
perd on finira deuxième de la course
1992 bertrand de broc va faire de la
couture sur sa langue déchiré par une
blessure
une séance d'auto chirurgie de points de
suture mené grâce aux conseils prodigués
au téléphone par jean yves chauve le
médecin de la course
1996 la troisième édition la plus agitée
du vendée globe au large de l'océan
indien dans le froid et la tempête
l'anglais bullimore après quatre jours
et quatre nuits à temps des reclus à
l'intérieur de son bateau qui avait
chaviré
une frégate de la marine australienne
récupéré sain et sauf grâce à une énorme
détermination et quelques carrés de
chocolat
quelques heures auparavant les secours
australiens hélitreuille le français
thierry dubois qui avait pris place dans
un canot de survie
1996 raphaël dinelli est à bord d'un
bateau qui a pris l'eau miraculeusement
il sera sauvé par l'anglais phil goss
qui se déroute le récupère en pleine mer
et le ramène à bon port en australie
lors de cette édition du vendée globe le
canadien gerry roufs disparaît dans des
conditions dantesques
on retrouvera son bateau jamais la mère
de rendre à son corps